hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice game from round six of the 2018
bill chess festival it's a game from
nicocure yeah this the local Swiss
Grandmaster in shock rare mama Dee are
off now Nico is not having the greatest
tournament so far from from the first
five rounds he lost four games but he
did draw one game and it's a game he
played against Magnus Carlsen so if
you're gonna draw him against someone
you know make it against the world
champion so before we check out this
very nice game we do have a nice photo
challenge it's a completely different
one because this time it's not a human
what we're looking for so there you have
it now I'm pretty sure like 99% of you
can recognize the Grandmaster on the
right it's of course lemon or onion over
me Nia but the photo challenge is
actually who is his canine friend on the
left
someone told me in the chat I believe
well well I posted this not this fall
but another photo of xi and this fellow
here that his name translates the donut
in Russian or something like that so
there we have it the best best of luck
to everyone now we do have a nice photo
of this matchup there you have it
it's a photo from the official bill
chest festival website there is a link
to it in the description below you can
check out some of the other photos I was
taken by Simone Bohan boost and we also
have another nice photo it's actually a
photo from a duck family also from the
official bill chess festival website I
don't know why it's there
probably a seaman head you know some
time before the run started so you know
he strolled around and took some nice
photos and you know it you know who
doesn't love a duck family so there we
have it now let's check out this game
Nico opens with E 4 we have C 5 the
Sicilian Knight to f3 d6 b 4c captures
Knight captures Knight to f6 so overly
standard Knight to c3 and mama D ro goes
for the knight of variation a6 bunch of
- e - e 5/9 to b3 as the knight was
attacked Bishop to e7
Bishop to e3 and Bishop to e6 and here
we have knife to d5
one of my favorite moves during during a
bullet and hyperbola games trying to get
black to capture Eve or pawn if black
captures
then of course Bishop to b6 comes
attacking the Queen and after the Queen
moves a knight c7 check wins do rockin a
a so a very nice idea but of course mama
dar does not capture the e4 pawn Knight
B to d7 is played Queen to d3 now and
now comes better captures on d5 pawn
captures on d5 and now rook the c8 we
have c4 we have castles by mama dr of
castles by niko and now what do you do
here well all of our pieces are pretty
much developed you definitely want to
find a nice square for your queen
although that's for a moment that's not
really possible it's not a c7 isn't such
a great square for the Queen
so what you want to do is somehow get
this pawn all the way to f5 and you know
it should somehow be protected on f5 so
Mahmud arrow goes Knight the EI
preparing f5 we have Queen to d2 and the
Queen to d2 is a very nice move because
it kind of discourages black from
pushing f5 immediately due to Queen to
b4 attacking the b7 pawn and after black
takes care of this in some fashion then
c5 would be an idea getting rid of this
week backwards pawn so after Queen to d2
mama D refers tends to the Queen side we
have b6 rook a to C 1 and now a5 not
allowing the Queen to even think about
coming to beforehand already a 4 it is
an idea to kick the night away from b3
night to a1 immediately in Eco brings it
back and he wants to push a 3 and B 4
not in that order of course if you push
a 3 then you will get a 4 but B 3 a 3
and only then before would be nice for
white but now the mama dr SE does have
you know a moment here he does push f5
we have f3 making room for the Bishop f4
Bishop to f2 and now MA media finds a
very nice way how to get his Queen into
the game he plays Bishop to h4 now of
course capturing the bishop would allow
the Queen to enter the game so we have
Bishop to d3 and now Bishop captures an
f2 with Czech Queen captures on f2 and
now comes Knight the c5 attacking the
bishop on d1 d3 we have Bishop to c2
which is not the greatest of moves
better would be Queen to c2 but
you know the idea is that you wanna you
want to have the C 2 square available
for this night at some point so if this
night will ever capture a bishop Quinn
will recapture and then the C 2 square
will be available for the night but okay
brush up the C - we have g6 now rope -
e1 and now comes Knight to g7 preparing
to bring the knight either to h5 or ff5
depending on what white place and here
Niko doesn't really like his setup he's
discouraged from going Knight to b3 to
try and get rid of blacks night here and
activate his a one night so rather brush
up to e4 displayed he wants to bring his
Knight over to see - so you know but you
know if he really wants to bring it to
see - it's better to do it this way then
- now play nice the b3 just because you
have a bishop on c2 so Queen to d7 and
now Knight the c2 we have nice to a5 and
now comes b3 King to h8 and a now look
to be one preparing a 3 and B 4 Knight
back to g7 we have knife 283 now Knight
to f5 and here we have Knights to b5
tonight is very useful there
Nico was able to activate it it's
pressuring the d6 pawn but also it can
become an active piece again maybe and
Knight to c3
rook to f6 bringing the rook over to
help out with the defense of the d6 pawn
but also maybe preparing to bring the
other rook over to the Kings side we
have a three and now comes g5 an
interesting idea here would definitely
be nice to e3 for some for some reason
Mamedov doesn't you know appreciate this
idea it's a very nice square for the
knight this e3 square and later you can
push maybe maybe
g5 and g4 and the idea is that it's not
all that easy to get rid of this knife
from e3 you would need to two moves with
this night to get rid of it but okay for
some reason manager of doesn't do it
instead he plays g5 and the Nico doesn't
think too much of this Knight move
either as he doesn't capture it with the
bishop rather he brings the knight back
into the game Knight to c3 we have night
to d4 now and now comes before a capture
some before and now rook capture some
before Nico doesn't play the
the a cap tourism before which seems
like a more obvious move attacking the
night and you know improving your pawn
structure but it would actually only
help black after night captures night
captures then Ruby g6 is coming and then
G for black is the only one that has
something to play here so after a
capture some before Nico plays rook cap
for some before now immediately
attacking the b6 pawn but mom in Europe
doesn't think twice he simply pushes g4
and starts attacking on the King side
now capturing the pawn here would gives
black simply too much after capturing
here you have to capture with the pond
and you opened up well of course not
with that rook but you've opened up the
G file and Queen a7 with an attack on
the roof can easily come into play via
the Queen side so after g4 we have Queen
to h4 now attacking Mahmud Arabs rockin
f6 but also pressuring the h7 square if
the Queen ever moves from d7 I will have
Knight captures on e4 Knight captures on
e4 and now comes rook to g6 of course
again pressuring this G captures here
and that's not the only threat mama TR
of has here of course there is an even
bigger threat well this is the biggest
threat but you know you can't stop
everything night the c2 is also a big
threat for King both rooks so here F
captures and g4 was played but there's
really nothing better to do if you move
the rook you know to avoid to avoid the
fork then capturing here will be a
winning game for black
so instead Nico tries F captures on g4
and he allows Knights the c2 as he does
have to do it we have rook after some b6
now comes Knight captures anyone and
here Nico doesn't capture the night here
although it does seem like the most
logical thing to do but Nico already
lost four games he only drew one and
he's going for he's going for everything
he's going all-in
he goes Knight to f6 now pressuring
again the h7 Square and also attacking
the Queen here and okay the night is
still attacked my madero plays Queen to
g7 still defending the h7 Square but
this comes with a double attack on the
night we have rook captures on d6 now
the night is defended twice but now a
very simple move takes care of every you
know every threat
Neko might have had in mind rook to h6
simply attacking an eco struck a Niko's
Queen and the Duke win has to move
there's really no wood square for the
Queen to keep this attacker going so
Queen captures anyone and now comes
rogue captures on f6 and it was in this
position that Nico decided to finally
resign the game there's really nothing
you can do here after characters
captures okay you do have three point
three past points these two are
connected past points but you know they
are there are no match for the rook so
yeah that's the game again from round
six of the 2018 bill chess festival and
before I forget I did prepare the final
not the final standings but the final
standings after the first you know leg
of this tournament as it is a double
round-robin so now that six games have
been played and now there will be a rest
day tomorrow and then we're gonna have
everyone will play against everyone once
again so there we have it mama D of took
the lead here four and a half points out
of six now across and in second place
four out of six you know none of them
have lost any games but since Coulson
was unable Causton is the only player in
this tournament who did not beat young
Nico so you know and that cost him first
place for now but you know the turn and
they're still another half to the
tournament so who knows what might
happen but you know a very nice a very
nice performance by Medea of definitely
then in third place we have Peter
Svidler than Davi Navarra
maxime beaugeois graph and then nicocure
goddess in last place with only half a
point
but those had that half a point came
from drawing a game with the world
champion Magnus Carlsen so yeah that was
the game I do hope you enjoyed it and
that you are enjoying the coverage of
this bill chess festival so far I would
like to thank James Kaczynski for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check - on my previous
videos here thank all for watching and I
will see you soon as tomorrow is the
rest day in Beal probably with to to
Bobby Fischer games or if something
comes up you know you never know when
they might you know bring alpha0 back
back to play chess you know we might
show something like that so yeah I think
oh and I will see
soon